this is the first interview you've given
so this all blew up so let's just cut to
the quick here when Rishi sunak the
British prime minister
says that Boris Johnson tried to get him
to effectively circumnavigate the rules
about the honors including yours
is he telling the truth
so he's using something which I called
think they're called sophistry which is
using a language and words in order to
deceive what Boris Johnson actually
asked him to do was to ask Colac to do
the re-betting which required to be done
then peace now can I just explain why
that's important so every six months a
re-betting has took place well I tell
you what I tell you what I spent this
easy for the viewers okay who aren't up
to speed on all the nuances let's go
back to the beginning yeah Boris Johnson
tells you when that he's intending to
make you a baroness when does he have
that first oh that was ages ago that was
back in the Autumn sometime it was a
private conversation you're not allowed
to talk about it afterwards it's a
private conversation to say that I'd
been put on his resignation on his list
to be a baroness yeah that's what it is
when you go into the Lords okay and what
was your reaction to that how did you
feel about that
it was quite emotional actually because
I never you know I've always revered the
House of Lords I think it's actually a
place where all I know a lot of people
criticize it but and make fun of it
almost but it's a place where all the
heavy lifting of the scrutiny of bills
actually takes place the comment has
become this like this set piece theater
for prime ministers questions and and
for other big pieces but actually we're
all the heavy lifting where the where
it's stacked full of people with
expertise and wisdom and knowledge it's
the Lords and so it's a kind of place
you look at I know there are a lot of
old useless duffers there as well
there may possibly be but I couldn't
comment but but there's also a lot of
like really serious heavy lifting goes
on there and it is a place that you know
God like for me from my background no
one would ever have dreamed that someone
from my background could get with people
who don't know your background why do
you say that so I was born in a place
called Breck Road in Liverpool which I
think is probably classified as one of
the forest streets in the country not
just in Liverpool one of the poorest
Wards and you know it was most of my
life you know the first almost 30 years
of my life were very tough it was you
know financially very very hard I
literally it sounds like something like
a Dickens novel but I literally had to
borrow shoes to go to school I literally
know what hunger pains feel like and you
know I've been a long time ago I was
born in 57 the 60s went great for you
know in the early 70s for surviving and
there wasn't a benefit system or you
know the safety net that there is today
for people so it was pretty tough and to
think that you know I didn't even know
what a university was I didn't know that
universities even existed it was it was
just something that the House of Lords I
wouldn't have known if you'd asked me a
21 you know the House of Lords even know
what it was so to be told that you're
being put on a list to be nominated to
go into the House of Lords it's just
like it's unbelievable and for me it's
so important because now I did this a
lot when I was sexual estate in dcms it
was all about making sure that ladders
were put down into those backgrounds to
give people opportunities to work in the
arts and culture because they are
because they don't now because the kind
of people who do work in arts and
culture do those who went to independent
school or you know whose dad's a
producer or whatever so for me it was
kind of that's the next stage you know
if I go into the Lords it actually sends
a signal to other people doesn't matter
where you come from doesn't matter what
you're born to doesn't matter how poor
you are if you if you you can get there
you know I call it the class stealing or
the class ceiling where I come from I
wanted to break that ceiling okay so it
means a lot to you yeah clearly I can
tell that right means a lot to you but I
would imagine serving your constituents
as a member of parliament also means a
lot to you yeah I mean
the great honors anyone can have in this
country yeah to be an elected official
representing your constituents so that
then obviously be an inevitable question
to come but from that moment Boris
Johnson
tells you that's his intention
do you just assume it's going to happen
so what I thought was I expected someone
to contact me and talk to me I thought
it might be holak who's the House of
Lords what's the normal procedure so
well there is this is why I couldn't
there's no normal procedure I couldn't
find this out the normal procedure I've
discovered is that whole act who is
holak House of Lords appointment
commission right so they and they had
the right to approve or discipline no
they have no right to approve or
disapprove so this rhetoric which has
been coming out of Downey street is that
the house of laws did not approve it
it's absolutely nonsense they don't have
that it's not their mandate so boss's
list goes into number 10 number 10 hand
it over to holak who act do the vetting
that's police checks and hmrc checks
then they hand that list back to number
10 number 10 then hand that list over to
the king so what happened was holak said
to number 10
this MP needs to pick a public
announcement that she will stand down
within six months of being put back to
you on this list nobody from number 10
communicated that to me
Morris found out about this and had a
meeting with Rishi last week
six months had elapsed since the betting
had been done why Downing Street waited
six months I have no idea six months
elapsed Boris said to British unit you
just need to ask for the re-veting which
would take a match of days Rishi used
very weasel words he said to Boris
Johnson and that's that's the only thing
Boris asked him to do he said to Boris
whatever list holak sent back to me I
will sign off both left that meeting
with the impression but James Forsyth
who is zoonat's political secretary was
going to ask for the re-veting for the
list to come forward and then Rishi
would sign it off but of course Rishi
was using those words because he knew a
situation had been engineered I.E the
information her like again had not been
not been communicated to me and
therefore my name would not be on the
list because I hadn't done what her like
asked number 10 to ask me to do because
nobody had asked me to do it I hope I
can let it be known that they did not
support some of the people that they
couldn't because they couldn't support
the people had been put forward because
we hadn't done what had been asked
that's the only reason that they
wouldn't support it it wasn't the
failure of any of the vetting no no no
absolutely not no right so there were
six people on this so This sounds like a
sort of murder mystery plot that you'd
have at a friend's dinner party who
who's the murderer here who has stopped
you Nadine Doris from joining the house
of laws do you believe the prime
minister
you think he personally intervened
um well he so very cleverly of course
not his political secretary James
Forsyth would do the the heavy lifting
the the the not passing the message on
not doing what hola asked it was James
Forsyth but obviously James boss Knight
works but I mean Joseph Smith is Rich
she's not his best friend he was his
best manager yeah but you're saying that
number 10 directly intervened to stop
you what they did join in miles of laws
what they did that's what you're saying
that right what they did was not pass on
the information from holak which was
she has to announce that she will stand
down with insects because you cannot be
an MP and sit in the house and you can't
be two in two houses you can't be in two
ledges such as that did you not know
that rule yes they knew but what we'd
been told via back channels was that
don't cause by-election there will be a
solution something's going to be found
that's what I was being told by it the
cabinet secretary and back channels so
that's my cabinet secretary said to you
is all going to be fine the the cabinet
secretary came up with a plan originally
with another cabinet secretary that
there would be a system that was put in
place Ruth Davidson an asterisk system
which meant we could go on the list and
we would stay there until a general
election we found out that suddenly that
wasn't allowed and then that's when
things that's when I began to get
suspicious started asking questions was
met with a wall of silence and then
Boris Johnson also began to think
something's not quite right here that's
why he asked the meetings especially
soon like number 10 I know why they did
this they did this because they wanted
to avoid a by-election if they'd worked
with me we could have had this
by-election a time which was suitable to
them maybe after the Autumn statements
come out when hopefully there'll be some
good news we've got to work together but
instead did did Rishi soon lie to Boris
did Boris lie did was she soon at lie to
Boris Johnson in their meeting so what
I've said to you is you use sophistry
some very clever words I will sign off
whatever list holak give to me knowing
full well that my name was not a mine
and other names were not on that list
because they had engineered that those
names were not on that list by not
informing us the requests made by holak
to number 10 informing us what we needed
are you sure Boris Johnson didn't take
you off that list
100 it wouldn't be the first time he's I
want these stiff people no I don't I
don't think that's true well it is true
well I don't believe it is my I can only
speakers my experience of rice Johnson
those I know and it's it's a very
positive you're certain that he wouldn't
have taken you off absolutely certain
absolutely son
Boris I mean for one of a better phrase
threw his toys out of the pram after all
this happened some say you did too you
appeared on talk TV no I didn't well I'm
going to throw you a clip from talk TV
this is before the news breaks this is
what you said to Mike Graham
the last thing I would want to do would
be to cause a by-election something
significant did happen to change my mind
and and I did do and I think it's for
the best
and literally hours later you quit and
provoked because I think significant did
happen and that there are two
significant things that happened to the
first was
um that I realized by a number of
conversations what had happened and the
reason why I realized what was happened
was
a phone call was made to Simon case on
Thursday evening and he was told no to
an aide at boris's office the cabinet he
was told no everything's fine her name's
on the list I phoned Boris phoned the
next morning iPhone the next morning we
were told I spoke to the chief whip
shortly actually so Thursday the cabinet
secretary confirms your name list with
an aide from boris's office so what
could have happened the time I was just
about to tell you okay so um I spoke to
the chief whip in the morning and he
said no everything's fine on Friday
morning the list was announced at four
o'clock on Friday afternoon I suppose
the chief whip on Friday morning he said
no no everything's fine everything's
fine there's he said let me let me go
make some inquiries and I'll get back to
you he got back to me 13 minutes before
the less was published and said actually
you're not on the list
30 minutes and you found out from a
journalist I found out from Steve swim
from the times on Thursday night and I
didn't believe him I thought he was
lying to me I said and I was crossed
with him I said Steve why are you doing
this you know I thought to myself why
isn't he just finding out the evidence
for this story properly someone is doing
this do you think you think the
motivation for what Downing Street you
believe did in stopping you uh getting
this honor is that they didn't want to
trigger a by-election which is pretty
ironic given is actually a good
connection three by-elections it's
pretty stupid actually not ironic it was
pretty stupid if they thought they were
being clever and avoiding by electricity
by thinking that they could play well of
course they're going to deny it are they
lying they are not telling the truth so
they're lying no they're not tying the
truth they're not telling the truth but
the Prime Minister said there were two
points then provinces they're going to
bring Integrity back to public life he's
certainly not doing that he's certainly
not doing that and you know do you
believe Richard sunak is lying about
this so there are three points there are
three issues that number two have lied
on they've lied on the fact that they
denied the meeting with Boris Johnson
even took place to begin they denied a
journalist and then accepted they had to
acknowledge the meeting did take place
then they lied and said that we were on
the list and everything was absolutely
fine they gave the impression to Boris
Johnson that they were going to ask for
the re-betting and that my name and
others would be on the list and it would
be signed off their lies were told in a
in a number of ways and what I don't
understand is the stupidity of it and
I've written about this in my column on
The Daily Mouse where I put a timeline
down about what actually happened what I
don't understand is the stupidity of
this and the psychodrama creation of it
and the one point I would make is you
know there were lots of criticisms about
what happened under virus John person
about the dramas that I compare to
number 10. well here's another one under
Rishi sunak and the entire time that the
dramas were occurring at number 10 while
Rishi sunak was number two working teeth
cheek by jail with borrow let me let me
ask you another one let me ask you know
why the point should somebody who's been
prime minister and has had to be forced
out of office in disgrace you may or may
not agree with why but that was the
reality should they be entitled to have
a resignation on us as many people I'm
one of them think that any prime
minister who has to quit in dishonorable
circumstances should abrogate the right
to have an honors this I'm not passing
judgment on you getting one or any
others right I'm just saying I don't
think that that is good for the system
so you know if there had been a shred of
evidence
to justify the findings of the
provisions Committee Against Boris
Johnson if they had what if they had
well there is more than a shred no there
isn't appears there is not a shred of
evidence so a privileges committee hang
on which has seven people on it four of
whom are eurosceptic brexit supporting
conservatives you're saying they set out
to destroy Boris Johnson the Prime
Minister who won a big majority and
delivered brexit you think that that's a
realistic scenario no I think that's a
very simplistic scenario that you've
presented because it's a fact because
when it well it isn't actually because
what takes place is that that committee
it's under scrutiny under a huge amount
of public scrutiny there are many events
that have taken place that have been
wrong with that committee for example
the submissions by Sue gray who we just
happen to know was working with labor at
the time here we just happened to know
employees accusations
Boris Johnson indisputably attended part
the Privileges committee made the
conclusions this made which clearly when
Boris read them he decided was so bad he
had to quit immediately peers I regard
the police as a higher authority they
find it they find him and Rishi sooner
she soon actually be driven out of
parliament because he was fined as well
well have you read this report or the
Privileges committee no I haven't right
so you know what this says so you're
convinced us to stitch up you haven't
read it I know the facts about the facts
that they're working on you know what
Boris told you if you're saying what
Boris says in the word fact are two
different things a lot of the time well
again we are never going to agree on
that but if what do you think he's
always tells the truth if Boris Johnson
has been driven out of parliament for
having Saturday's desk and not eating a
piece of cake when people he was working
with all day in the same offices came
into that room to wish him happy
birthday if you think that is the basis
for driving him out of office I think
he's more than that I think it's more
than there were the karaoke parties on
the night before no he wasn't it's his
home no it's not his home he was in
checkers it's his home no Piers well so
again that's correct to point there it's
Rishi who lives above number 10. Boris
lived above number 11 next door it was
rishi's home it's Bryce's office during
the day but it was actually rishi's home
are you actually going to quit as an MP
yeah I've resigned there's no way back
some people think you may you may change
your mind that you were being a bit
hot-headed no so I never formally
resigned you haven't let me explain to
you the significant thing that happened
to change my mind to make me oh God it
was the sheer audacity of the chief whip
thinking but at my age after having
worked in Parliament for 21 years
serving 18 years on the back benches
having been a minister during covered in
help having been a secretary of state
that he could dangle out me some kind of
stick and carrot like be a good girl and
we'll make sure something's sorted for
you in the future which is basically
what he was saying to me that for me at
that moment was what made me change my
mind and made me make my decision too
how upset are you at now not getting
this honor you assumed you were going to
get not joining the House of Lords not
being baroness at the end of all this
Julie what I'm broken-hearted not just
for me but for everybody who comes from
a background like mine
who in today's world don't have the
ability to climb ladders that they used
to have years ago who who struggled to
Aspire because they feel that it just
isn't worth being aspirational it isn't
worth working hard because they see
others from different backgrounds who
take the spoils and it kind of breaks my
heart because that that's what this
story is this story is about a girl from
Breck Road and Liverpool who worked
every day of her life since she was 14
years old had something offered to her
for that people from that background
don't get offered removed by two
privileged Posh boys who went to win
Winchester and Oxford and taken away
duplicity and crawly because they have
known for months that it wasn't the case
and yet they let me and they let Boris
Johnson continue to believe that was the
case it was upsetting and It's upsetting
for everybody who thinks that one day
they could be that person because you
know what if you come up against someone
like Rishi sunak and James Forsyth from
privileged backgrounds who have it all
very easily given to them on a plate
you're in trouble you won't make it
because they can do whatever they want
to stop it there are a lot of people
there are a lot of people who would say
exactly same about your mate Boris that
you won't get anyone who's been more
privileged than him or he went to Eaton
who has glided effortlessly through life
people say on the bones of his backside
most of his life you had no money he's
always been on the bones of his backside
most of his life
scholarship he is you cannot make that
comparison here's what's about Boris I
like him personally always have done
right but I think the way he has run the
country has been a disgrace and that's
why he's got his comeuppance and when
this report comes out maybe even as soon
as tomorrow you will read it and you
might be surprised about what they are
on earth it wasn't a Witch Hunt it
wasn't a stitch up why would it be four
of the seven on the committee
distinguished conservatives who voted
for brexit I'll tell you why it would be
because one of the main contributors to
that report was Sue gray who's now gone
to work for Kirsten and who wants Boris
gone out of Westminster more than Rishi
sunak kirst armor does we'll never agree
well that okay final question
you handing him a by-election which they
will now probably gang up with the lib
Dems to win yeah how does that help your
party
my party isn't helping itself no but why
are you knifing the party I'm not knife
in the party in a way you are no players
I think you come to a point in life when
you have when you have to stop when you
can't just be pushed around when you
can't allow people to bully you as I've
just been bullied by number 10 you can't
allow that to happen you have to stand
up for yourself and that's what I did
it's a painful decision I didn't know
when I said to Mike in the morning I did
not want to cause a by-election I've
Loved serving it's been a great fun of
my life to serve mid beverage for 18
years leaving it in the lurch like this
to go to this by-election was not what I
wanted you said a moment ago about what
a what an honor it is when I my majority
was 24 600 when those people 38 000
people went out and voted for me the
last election those people went out and
put their cross next to my name that is
the biggest anyone and they'll be
watching this thinking well why have you
abandoned this I think they'll
understand
yeah I think they'll understand and I
think they'll think we wouldn't let
anyone do that to us either
Nadine thank you for coming in I
appreciate it